[Music]
hello it's seven o'clock this is sky
news breakfast these are our top stories
here this morning
a warning delays at dover and on the
roads could get worse today as holiday
attempt to get away for the summer break
here at dover ferry passengers have been
told to allow at least five hours for
boarding as france is blamed for long
queues and delays at the port
in the tory leadership race rishi sunak
promises to tackle nhs backlogs while
liz trust vows to review remaining eu
laws
steve bannon a long-term ally of donald
trump is convicted after refusing to
cooperate with the investigation into
the storming of the capital
millions of tons of grains will be
exported from ukraine again after a
landmark deal is agreed with russia
how did you find me
you make a lot of noise
and we talk bond bollywood and family
life on set with the actor ryan gosling
as he prepares the star in his first
action
movie in sport there's a fourth british
medal at the world athletics
championships as matthew hudson-smith
takes bronze in the 400 meters
and at the close to 8 we'll take a look
at the papers with the political editor
at the sunday mirror nigel nelson and
the journalist and author gemma forte
[Music]
hello anna very good morning to you
welcome to sky news breakfast
now holidaymakers are being warned to
expect more disruption and major delays
across large parts of southern england
in what's expected to be one of the
busiest days of the year on the roads
after schools broke up for the summer
a lack of french immigration staff has
been blamed for a critical incident at
the port of dover yesterday with bumper
to bumper six mile cues
but the french mp for calais says the
problems were an aftermath of brexit
and things could be just as bad if not
worse over the course of the weekend so
here's what we're expecting
piano ferris has told passengers to
allow at least five hours when heading
to the port of dover saying it expects
it to be just as busy today
the aaa says that drivers should expect
disruption and delays on major holiday
routes to the southwest to the eastern
coast and to the ports of dover and
folkston
while the rsc says almost 19 million
cars are expected to hit the road for
leisure trips over the course of the
weekend
so our sky correspondent madeline
radcliffe joins me now from dover so
terrible day for people trying to get
across the channel yesterday from there
madeline and it doesn't look like
there's going to be a huge improvement
today
morning anna no sadly not the queues
were already starting at 4 00 a.m here
at dover this morning
and you can see down just below me here
they are building up lines and lines of
cars queuing just to get to frontier
control that borders those border checks
once they're through and for once it's
not the lorries we can see lined up here
it is just passenger cars holiday makers
once they're through the rest of the
port seems to be moving okay but it is
stacked up and um that warning that
today could be as bad or even worse than
yesterday with gridlock six hour waits
or more certainly looks like it could be
that again today
some of these cars haven't moved in the
last hour
and you know passengers parents down
there trying to keep children happy at
the start of their holidays it is not a
good start to your summer holiday at all
um but of course while the passengers
are waiting and waiting there is a blame
game being paid here it all started
yesterday when the boss of the port of
dover blamed the french that it was the
fault of the french that these huge
queues had both built up this critical
incident they had understaffed their
border um control posts and let the port
down after months of planning um the
french police said it wasn't their fault
there had been an unexpected technical
error
but that prompted an intervention from
the foreign secretary liz truss who has
called these delays both unavoided um
avoidable even and appalling and she has
demanded that the french take action to
increase their staffing saying she will
work with them to find a solution the
transport secretary grant chaps has also
said he's going to work with the french
but it has prompted a backlash the
french mp for calais has said this is a
result of brexit the port of dover is
not big enough they said
and this is a brexit uh
dividend effectively we know that that
uh those passport checks do take longer
now post-brexit there is more to do um
but whether it's uh
understaffing or passports it doesn't
make much difference for the people who
have to wait and wait and there's no
sign of an end to that backlog
indeed a really tough for those people
heading to dover let's uh hope that the
experience is slightly better for them
today madeline thanks very much indeed
well let's turn to the race for number
10 now and rishi sunak will make his
first major speech since reaching the
final two of the tory leadership
election later today in grantham
margaret thatcher's hometown of course
the former chancellor will be setting
out his plans to tackle the nhs backlog
as he views to win the votes of party
members well i'm joined now by health
minister and rishi sunax supporter maria
caulfield a very good morning to you and
i want to come on to richie sunak's
plans for the nhs in just a moment but
first i wonder if i could get your
reaction to at those scenes there at
dover that we were just hearing about a
piano ferries telling people heading
there today to again allow at least five
hours to try to to get through those
cues i just wondered what your reaction
was to that and tell us what the
government is trying to do about it
well it's obviously very frustrating for
passengers and for freight as well uh
that there's such delays and for the
people of dover as well because they're
the they're often having to live with
these uh long queues uh and it's
frustrating if uh you know french
authorities haven't got uh the border
control staff that are needed at the
dover side and i do understand they've
also been hit by uh technical
difficulties as well uh but i'm
welcoming the fact that grant chaps is
um in talks with them is trying to get
it resolved because uh we want to to
make sure that passengers at start of
the summer holiday season are able to
get away in a timely fashion i've got
port myself in new haven we're not
experiencing these delays so it does
seem to be something that's quite
specific to dover
okay well let's move on then to rishi
sunak's plans for the nhs he wants to
tackle the backlog and has pledged
hasn't he um that one-year wait will be
eliminated by september 2024 that's
bringing forward that target by six
months
but there's been a lot of doubts in the
nhs that that original target could be
reached so is it really feasible him in
saying that
well if you look at the work we've been
doing around the backlog remember you
know covid uh cut you know really cut
down any routine care for almost two
years so we've got a backlog people
waiting for surgical procedures but also
people waiting for investigations as
well and the two-year wait we had around
about 23 000 people uh waiting for
procedures over two years we got those
down uh this month so we are on track uh
it's the 18 month and uh the year
waiters now that we're really focusing
on they're a bigger group of people but
that's why i welcome the intervention by
rishi because it is going to need a
concerted effort we're seeing right now
at the moment in the nhs winter time
pressures because while as you saw in
dover people are going on holiday now
they're back to work they're back to
school and kovid is still with us and
we've seen really high numbers of covid
uh in our hospitals people
in with covid or because of covid
and you know that is putting pressure on
the system to deal with some of the
elective backlogs we're still on track
to do that but any intervention such as
a task force to help us deal with that
backlog can only be welcomed
but how much can a task force actually
achieve when there's a obviously his
focus is on the nhs but there's very
little mention here about social care
provision and a lot of doctors will say
you can't make any real impact
without addressing that
well we saw with the covert vaccine just
what a task force can do you know
it turned this country into one of the
leading uh countries in the vaccine uh
rollout and particularly across europe
so a task force actually can have a
significant impact and with elective
procedures you know increasing our uh
centers of diagnostic centers to 200
will significantly make an impact
because we've already with our 90 uh
they're open right now delivered over a
million tests and they're the sorts of
things like x-rays cts ultrasounds
biopsies you know to increase that to
200 as rishi's planning will have a
significant effect an elective sorry
sorry it's not but just brought about
the issue of social care provision
because a lot of doctors will say that
you need to be able to try and get
medically fit patients back at home and
they need support there and if you
haven't got social care provision you
can't free up those beds and that will
make a massive difference wouldn't it so
where's the mention of social care in
his plans
so social care absolutely but that's why
this government has uh introduced what's
called the integrated care boards that's
bringing health and social care together
for the first time ever across 42 local
areas
in england and that is already uh making
a difference i met with all the chairs
of those icb
boards this week specifically to talk
about social care they're working really
hard uh to uh not just get places in
care and residential homes but also
domiciliary care which is people going
into people's homes um together because
that is a significant factor but it's
not the only factor you know our
hospital rates are really high at the
moment across the board because we are
seeing patients on average staying for
16 percent longer because patients in
hospital are often sicker we're also
seeing the high rates of covid uh in
hospital uh usually people who are in uh
with other things but have covered and
we're also we were racing with high uh
vacant uh absence rates from staff we've
got about a six percent absence rate
across the nihs at the moment again
because of covid so there are multiple
factors um fixing just one of them will
not get the solution that we need and
that's why a task force is essential to
look at all of those factors in the
round
what about the issue of recruitment and
retention of doctors that seem to be
crucial isn't it to the smooth running
of the nhs and there are a lot of
doctors that would say at the moment
that the nhs pension rules at the moment
mean that it's more financially
attractive often to quit working at that
to continue practicing is that being
addressed by rishi sunad well absolutely
i mean obviously the pension rules when
i speak to doctors do have an impact for
for high earners uh they reach a certain
level and then they are hit by those uh
pension rules uh but it is more than
that you know we are recruiting we've
had uh four thousand more doctors in the
nhs uh this year we've got all our
places uh with medical students and
being filled we've announced recently
the apprenticeship route into medical
training so uh that students can earn
and learn while they're studying so
retention is a really important part but
it's not again it's not the only factor
we are recruiting more um doctors and
nurses um into the nhs um and we are
seeing the difference that that is
making
rishi sunayak according to the polls out
yesterday from yougov is a fair bit
behind amongst party members um
behind liz trust he's got a long way to
go how much difference do you think
these plans will make
well i think you know seeing the plans
that he has for the economy for
immigration for the nhs is is really
important and i would say on the
doorstep when i'm knocking or in my
constituency the two big issues are the
cost of living and rishi has got a
really good track record on supporting
people through the cost of living
pressures we're facing right now but the
second issue is the nhs you know people
do want to be able to see their gp's uh
more easily they do want to be able to
get a dentist appointment they want if
they're on the waiting list they want to
get their their treatment uh sorted as
quickly as possible so knowing that
there it's his three priority areas i
think will make a difference to people
and also if you look at the polling
rishi is the only one uh on the polling
that can beat kia stammer and i think
for conservative members based on that
aren't they sorry to interrupt
well no you know it's very clear um
consistent polling has shown that rishi
would be uh kia stammer in a general
election and for conservative members
that is the ultimate uh kind of ambition
is to keep winning both in local
elections next year but in a general
election when it comes
okay well maria caulfield we appreciate
your time this morning thanks very much
indeed for talking to us thank you
well uh our political correspondent
rappel was listening in there so rob
interesting rishi sunak making the nhs
one of his main focuses as he kicks off
this two-horse race
yeah i think so far rishi sunak hasn't
put much sort of new out new policy if
you like a lot of it has been based on
his previous achievements previous
policies while in the treasury while
chancellor i think now there is a sense
that because ballot papers will start
being delivered to conservative members
the week after next so potentially could
be footpath voted uh they could return
their ballot papers and they can vote
from the beginning of august really it's
the next 10 days that rishi sunak has
that are most important to try and
change minds and to try and level this
race a little bit
so that is why today he is going to
grantham in lincolnshire margaret
thatcher's
hometown
and he's going to talk about putting the
government the country on a crisis
footing if he goes into downing street
to deal with national emergencies around
the economy around migration but also
around the nhs and that's what he's
going to talk most about
today and you touched on some of the
ideas there with maria caulfield about
new diagnostic centers and surgical hubs
and a task force as well as you pointed
out to her i think the big issues are
going to be having enough people to work
in some of those hubs and also freeing
up beds by potentially
allowing people to move out into social
care
settings on that question of polling you
pointed out to maria colfield that
actually more recently some of the polls
look
a little bit tighter and that is correct
when it comes to rishi sunak and
kirstama there was one out a day or two
ago from redfield and wilton strategies
that i've got here where people are
asked which of the following individuals
do britain's think would be a better
prime minister for the united kingdom um
and rishi sooner comes out below
kierstarma but liz trust actually does
better in that so
it's not necessarily completely
clear-cut
that rishi sunak is the only candidate
that could be kirstama at the moment
there is some evidence that actually
kierstama is looking in a good position
against both of them of course as well
liz truss will be out and about to stay
she's talking about repealing brexit
rules and pitching herself as the brexit
delivery prime minister so both
candidates i think know that the next 10
days uh will be crucial and are getting
some of their big policy promises out
there
indeed and we'll hear lots about them
this weekend uh rob thanks very much
indeed
and just a reminder that a head-to-head
is going to take place here on sky news
in a live televised debate between those
two candidates kay burley is going to be
hosting that program on thursday the 4th
of august and it's at 8 00 pm
now one of donald trump's closest allies
and influential former adviser faces
being sent to prison for up to two years
after he was convicted of refusing to
cooperate with an investigation into
riots at the u.s capitol
steve bannon refused to testify or hand
over crucial documents to the committee
looking into the attack on the january
the 6th last year and he's said to have
been acting as an unofficial adviser to
mr trump at the time
sky's sally lockwood reports from
washington
steve bannon is the first of donald
trump's inner circle to be convicted as
a result of investigations into the
attack on the u.s capitol what'd you
think of the hearing last night sir
more show trial
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth at the root of this guilty
verdict is his refusal to testify
in thursday's explosive evidence we
learned that while the capital was under
attack donald trump was refusing to call
off the mob instead watching the riot
unfold on television from a dining room
in the west wing
it was during these hours of violence
the former chief strategist had contact
with donald trump according to the
committee
and he declared this on his radio show
after speaking to the president the day
before
all hell is going to break loose
tomorrow it's all converging and now
we're on as they say the point of attack
right the point of attack tomorrow i'll
tell you this
it's not going to happen like you think
it's going to happen
steve bannon now plans to appeal his
guilty verdict
we may have lost a battle here today but
we're not going to lose this war you
will see this case reversed on appeal
you will see all of these resources
three federal prosecutors four fbi
agents for a misdemeanor
are being wasted
we don't yet know if criminal charges
will be brought against donald trump all
those in his orbit following the january
the sixth hearings but steve bannon is
already facing prison time for simply
failing to comply
sally lockwood sky news washington
ukraine's president vladimir zelinsky
has welcomed a deal between russia and
ukraine over grain exports saying it's
another sign his country can withstand
the war in the most significant
agreement involving the warring parties
so far russian and ukrainian officials
signed deals with the un and turkey to
resume grain exports through the black
sea to help avert a global food crisis
about 20 million tons of last year's
grain harvest will be exported
this year's harvest which is already
being harvested will also be available
for sale
these are farmers incomes the entire
agricultural sector and the state budget
these are jobs and funds for planting
next year
we already have about 10 billion dollars
worth of grain
making the news this morning at least 13
people including a 12 year old child
have been killed in clashes between
competing militias in libya's capital
tripoli it's the latest escalation to
threaten the relative peace after nearly
a decade of civil war
a mother and her long-term partner have
been found guilty guilty of murdering
her fifteen-year-old son
sebastian kalinovski was killed after a
campaign of torture at his home in
huddersfield
his mother agnieszka kalinovska and her
partner andrei latazewski will be
sentenced later this year
thousands of gcse and a-level results
could be delayed after staff at the exam
board aqa announced a 72-hour walkout
over pay
unison members will strike for three
days from next friday with union warning
that action could escalate unless talks
are reopened
now that we're going to take a look at
what the weather's up to this weekend
now
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now there's wind and rain in the weekend
forecast as low pressure crosses the
country the southeast will be mostly
fine however and it'll become warmer for
many with temperatures in the mid-20s
celsius on sunday with a potential high
of 29 degrees celsius
after a largely dry start for the uk
mainland cloud will increase from the
west as rain already over ireland
crosses the irish sea to reach wales and
southwest scotland
eastern counties meanwhile we'll see the
best of the sunshine
let's get more out on our top story and
travelers are being warned the gridlock
in dover which led to six-hour queues
yesterday could get worse over the
course of the weekend deported over
declared a critical incident yesterday
as france was blamed for not having
enough border staff
let's get the latest now joining me is
the conservative mp fort dover natalie
elfic
very good morning to you thanks so much
for joining us what a nightmare for
holidaymakers trying to get on a ferry
at dover yesterday no doubt huge
knock-on effect for people living
in dover as well so what is the latest
situation i noticed that piano a warning
of possible five-hour delays again today
so so what do you understand is
happening there now
well it was a dreadful start to that
summer getaway yesterday and an
appalling situation for residents in
dover too um there was simply one in our
french border police today i'm hearing
that the french workers have turned up
and they're expected to be manning the
booths at capacity but there will be a
knock-on effect as there always is when
there's an issue that's happened at the
ports we're expecting long long delays
today traffic has already been building
up throughout the town and it's going to
be a very serious situation on the roads
again in kent today
well yes and
you talk about the fact that there
weren't enough french border staff and
the french have said
they did plan for a very busy travel day
but they did acknowledge that some of
their staff didn't turn up on time they
said that there was an incident in the
the channel tunnel that that caused the
problem
do you accept that was this just an
unlucky one-off
well the euro tunnel said that was not
the case it was nonsense and clearly i
speak to the port of dover here on the
ground and they were very clear
throughout the day yesterday that that
simply wasn't the case there were not
enough border staff it is the case that
preparations were made this is the
busiest time that we've had so far this
year it's a peak getaway time and it's
absolutely vital that travellers are um
with through uh those controls and on
their way on those ferries to france
that didn't happen yesterday it's
looking better on the ground today but
backlogs they build up very very quickly
it's very fragile infrastructure here at
the port of dover and across kent roads
if something goes wrong it takes many
hours to clear and that's what we're
expecting to see today
i noticed that the um french mp for
calais is talking about brexit he says
that this is a an aftermath of
of brexit and it's true to say that the
checks do take longer now don't they
your passport has to be stamped as you
go through um by border officials rather
than just being waved through as would
have happened in the past
well there are queues in dover before
brexit and there have been queues after
we've left the eu and the capacity of
these booths have been significantly
increased nearly doubled at the port of
dover to make sure that the french can
get the border officers there to do the
checks that they want to do so the
capacity is here at dover for those port
controls what happened yesterday is
simply the workers did not turn up to
work in the numbers that were needed to
meet this peak getaway season i
understand that they are here today that
the booths are going to be working at
full capacity and it appears to be
moving smoothly through the booths and
onto the ferries this morning but it
will take time for that backlog to clear
and it is vital that travellers take
precautions on the roads today that they
take water they take food they take
regular stops wherever they can at the
service stations and they allow extra
time for travel here on the ground i've
been working with kent police to try and
keep that traffic moving around the town
so we don't see the gridlock that we saw
yesterday
we've heard liz trust expressed a
certain amount of frustration over this
situation she's called it unacceptable
do you think generally there is a good
spirit of cooperation between the uk and
the french in managing this border are
there good relations over this
well here in dover we are a border town
you know we have very close relations
with counterparts on the french side
what happened yesterday was that the
french let everyone down with that lack
of delivery against the needed
preparations but work happens all the
time with the french and it's absolutely
vital that we keep that close
cooperation so that we can have the
trade that we can have the tourism that
we can have the free flow that we want
to see on the ferries here in dover but
as a dover mp i also want to make sure
that people in dover can get out and
about to do what they need in their
daily lives and when the town's in
gridlock that doesn't happen
could the uk do more to improve the
system prevent these bottlenecks
well the system is very fragile on the
roads here and i've been calling for a
long time for investment in not just the
roads here particularly on the a2 which
is part of the national road improvement
program but also to have lorry parks and
check-in facilities
so that we can take some of that traffic
off the roads and take the pressure off
it you know this is an incredibly
successful port and dover is an
incredibly successful town we want to
see that success continue for both
support and the town to grow and for
that to happen we must invest in our
border infrastructure that means
investing here at the port of dover and
investing in the kent roads right across
the county too
could this situation get worse in the
future there are plans for the schengen
zone the european schengen zone to
introduce biometric tests that's going
to slow things down even more isn't it
there are new biometric tests coming in
and again there's been considerable work
on how those are going to be
accommodated it just underlines the
importance as we go forward to make sure
that there is investment in new border
facilities that will allow these checks
to be made and lorry parking to ensure
that julia's can have their rest breaks
in the right way
if they are going to get caught in
traffic and fundamentally for me here in
dover is making sure that those traffic
systems are robust enough so dover
doesn't go into gridlock and residents
can get out and about in their daily
lives along with the port traffic being
able to get smoothly through to the port
well yes and uh we uh keep our fingers
crossed for the residents of dover but
also all those uh queuing out to get
their ferry this weekend natalie elfic
mp for dover thanks very much indeed
you're watching scandi's breakfast do
stay with us coming up we're going to
take you through the front pages with
the political editor of the sunday
mirror nigel nelson and the journalist
and author emma forte that's coming up
next
[Music]
climate change is with us and it's
becoming critical but the fight back is
on
coal is under fire whereas wind power is
booming
you can now have burgers made out of
these rather than those
and no need for fuel just rely on the
vital spark
i'm tom heap and i'm joining sky news
for special weekend editions of the
climate show where we'll meet the people
hit by the crisis and also those
delivering crafty solutions
in the end the question is can we reach
a world that isn't based on
burning stuff
find out on the climate show on skype
we're going to turn our attention to the
newspapers now with us to review them
this morning our political editor of the
sunday mirror nigel nelson and
journalist and author gemma forte so
welcome back to both of you and we're
delving inside the papers this hour
aren't we um gemma you've spotted a
story inside the mirror this is page two
of the mirror about
how
more people are paying for
their treatment their medical treatment
well that's right and obviously i feel
incredibly privileged as do many to live
in a country where something happens to
you you get this healthcare and it's
immediate and it's free
um i mean i know we pay our taxes but
the model in america you know doesn't
bear thinking about but we are at a
situation now where the nhs is on its
knees they are operating with literally
a scout what would have been in the past
called skeleton staff
um and there are many reasons for this
um they've obviously been blighted
they've come through a pandemic but we
have to look at what was going on before
the pandemic as well
and before the pandemic there were a
hundred thousand vacancies and there was
a four million waiting list that has
crept up to six point i think six
million so what's happening is
something's happening to someone perhaps
they need a hit replacement ordinarily
they would get their date for that
operation and it might be in a few
months time but now people are hearing
that's not going to be happening for a
year or two people are in agony and even
if they don't have private health
insurance they are choosing to go into
debt to get a loan um to pay for for
instance a hip operation would cost you
12 000 pounds so when you look just at
figures at how much these things cost
the value that hopefully
well not hopefully it means you're real
but you know even if you have a baby or
whatever it is on the nhs the value is
quite phenomenal there are no quick
fixes it takes a long time to train
nurses people talk about they're not
being a magic money tree there is not a
magic nurse dr porter cleaner tree
either but the nhs is crying out for
help and it's unfair people are paying
their taxes and then if they're paying
to have a private operation they are
essentially paying twice and that's not
how it's been but it's how it is now
well yes and nigel the nhs makes the
front page of the daily telegraph as
well and a suggestion here about
how the costs have really
increased but is there value for money
according to this
article well no that's that that's the
whole point and it sort of reinforces
gemma's point point a second ago
um this is a report from the civitas
think tank
and what it's saying is that where um
each household in britain is now paying
out ten thousand pounds a year in health
care
um obviously that's through taxes uh and
um
but
that is the third highest in europe but
outcomes are some of the worst with 50
000 unnecessary deaths
i think frankly we really do have to
grasp the nettle here
and recognize that while the people who
work in the nhs are absolutely wonderful
a structure that was designed in 1948
really isn't fit for purpose in 2022
and that's why the whole uh basis of the
nhs needs some fundamental reform
well yes and it's something nigel that
rishi sunak is focusing on today he's
doing a speech later this morning uh
he's talking about some of the big
emergencies facing the country and he
highlights the nhs as one of them
as far as the leadership
contest goes is that a a good
way of reaching the party members do you
think
yes and i think that the the key things
at the moment are obviously uh number
one is the cost of living crisis
um and number two certainly must be how
we actually get the the nhs as jimmy
just put it which is on its knees back
on its feet again so yes it is a good
area and it's not just a matter for the
party membership this is going to be a
crucial subject for the next general
election well yes and gemma what do you
make of this because here's rishi sunak
saying this is a real problem the nhs
and yet he and his contender
liz truss have both been in government
for many years in senior positions is
that a difficult argument to make do you
think
i think so and the thing is i think a
lot of this has been deliberate and
badly managed and quite negligent
because if you look at 2010 i.e before
the tories got in satisfaction levels
were at their highest and the cost per
person was around the three and a half
thousand pound mark compared to in
america with the private health model
seven and a half thousand where
satisfaction levels were entirely low in
12 years they've managed to flip that
and it's almost like many people within
that cabinet want to head towards a
private model so we have to be careful
at looking at why we have got where we
are and not perhaps saying it's not fit
for purpose but perhaps it has been
deliberately run down with austerity as
well it's been picked out like a carcass
until there's nothing left and it can't
cope
but i yeah and i would certainly say
that the people within it would would
have that um would have that view okay
that's an interesting take on it okay um
jeremy you've spotted a story inside the
star and we've heard a fair bit about
various strikes going on now um an exam
board is um proposing a strike and it
could affect when
students get their results is that right
i know and it is so i mean
teenagers have had the worst few years i
have to so
um my heart goes out to them because
they've just you know to be isolated at
that age particularly was incredibly
difficult and those are repercussions
socially and so on when it when it's all
ended has been has been something to get
our heads around and now to have perhaps
their exam results delayed is going to
be really horrendous for them but that
said
nobody goes on strike for a laugh nobody
goes on strike because they feel like it
i really don't believe that is true i
think all workers who consider strike it
is a very very last resort and the
people who are considering striking here
are people with families and with bills
to pay and obviously with inflation
rising to whatever it is at the moment i
think nine percent and everybody in the
public sector suffering a real
terms pay cut i understand so it
horrendous for the kids that they have
to suffer but i also have in huge
sympathy for people who are genuinely
panicking about how they can afford to
live and again
you know if you wanted to give every
single public sector worker a 10 pay
rise you'd need to find 20 20 billion
okay
um well we're about to pay a brexit bill
for 42 billion you know it's just
incredibly unfortunate or there's 35
billion that goes on tax avoidance and
so you can understand workers
frustrations and it's building up and
it's like hang on a minute you know i've
had enough uh you know mps get pay rises
and so on so there's a lot of discontent
about well yeah i mean nigel how does
the government approach this because
they keep arguing that giving these
you know pay rises to match inflation is
in itself inflationary and it would make
the matter worse but that's no
consolation for anybody who's
essentially getting a cut at a time when
their bills are going up it's how do how
do they get through this
no you're absolutely right and if you
actually do give pay rises uh at or
above inflation that it that it just it
just enhances inflation
however the examiners are being offered
three percent and three percent just
isn't good enough i mean you've got uh
inflation as jimmy just said going up to
nine percent now uh probably 11 by the
end of the year
so um what i'd like to see and i think
this applies both to the private and the
public sector is not pay rises of three
percent what we should be looking for is
somewhere halfway at five or six percent
and that probably would stave off the
industrial unrest that the whole country
is beginning to suffer from okay
nigel i'm going to stick with you
because you uh want to talk about a
double page spread in the mail today um
about um how boris johnson was was
pushed out of the top job so what what's
this article saying
well this is an andrew pierce piece
which is a kind of anatomy of how um
boris fell
a lot of it we know already but some of
the interesting
bits there are how much the boris cam
thought rishi sunap was
plotting against him and had been for
some time
so it was indications like rishi sunak
stopped turning up for private meetings
with the prime minister which was
something they did quite frequently
and at that point boris johnson actually
suspected that his chancellor was trying
to plot against him which has turned out
to be true what i find interesting about
this um is that a the the mail is a liz
trust supporting paper but if this turns
out to be true
it will do rishi sunak's chances no good
whatsoever with the conservative party
membership who are pretty angry that
boris johnson was brought down the way
he was
and if it turns out that rishi sunak had
been plotting this for some time
i think that will lose him votes
interesting it's going to be there's
going to be a lot of column inches
written about at this period aren't
there and especially over the weeks
ahead with the leadership contest and
i'm sure we'll be talking about it again
but for the moment we're going to say
goodbye but i'll see you again in the
next hour and nigel and gemma thanks
very much indeed
do you stay with us dr stories
[Music]